on this wednesday night russia tightens
its grip on ukraine
russian forces gaining some ground as
ukrainians keep fighting back the
multiplying casualties and the
humanitarian crisis we're living in real
health the alberta farmer who flew to
poland to help these are my people
providing shelter and safe haven
ukraine's hospitals under siege they're
under the strain of constant bombing
fears the crisis will collapse the
health care system and taking a hike it
could actually have a positive long-term
effect the rise of canada's benchmark
interest rate
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
air raid sirens and reports of loud
explosions in the ukraine capital
tonight a week into russia's war on
ukraine the bombardments are
intensifying
in parki ukraine's second largest city
buildings were hit in the city's center
ukraine state emergency services says 2
000 civilians have been killed that
number impossible to verify ukrainians
continue to try to hold back russian
forces these people blocked an access
point to ukraine's largest nuclear power
plant but russian forces are making
inroads
good evening and thanks for joining us
the pentagon says it believes vladimir
putin intends to topple the ukrainian
government and that the russians still
have a significant amount of combat
power that they have not used our
coverage begins with jeff semple
ukraine's largest most densely populated
cities are now under fire
russian rockets rain down on the
southern cities of mariopol and nearby
herself the strategically important city
of 300 000 is now under russian control
russian soldiers patrolling the streets
making it the first major city to fall
since the war began last week and
forming the makings of a
russian-controlled land bridge between
crimea and the donbass region
in the northeast this is what's left of
ukraine's second largest city of
harkheed home to one and a half million
people police headquarters university
and residential buildings obliterated
bodies in the streets incredibly this
woman was pulled from the rubble alive
but ukraine says more than 2 000
civilians have now been killed and there
are fears that death toll is about to
increase dramatically kiev is
effectively cut off and surrounded
russia's military has now encircled the
ukrainian capital many of its remaining
residents now scrambling to leave people
are saying
today is the last day to
leave caves including this woman who
arrived to find the last trains already
full
these pregnant women and newborns are
now hiding in the cellar of this kiev
maternity hospital we're living in real
hell i could never imagine that
something like that can happen in 21st
century
in a
capital of the european
country russia has so far failed to
claim the capital this nearby russian
military convoy has been stuck here for
days for the first time the russian
defense ministry confirmed a number of
casualties nearly 500 russian troops
killed ukraine claims the true number is
closer to 5 000. the russian war machine
has misfired what we're seeing now from
tuesday onwards is a regrouping a change
in tactics much more brutal tactics with
this proverbial gun to their head
ukrainian officials will meet their
russian counterparts for more talks on
thursday most expect russia won't accept
anything less than a complete
capitulation but these pictures of
ukrainians defiant fearlessly blocking
the streets in front of their
communities don't look like people who
are about to surrender should they make
a kind of conservative move on key of
the capital they're going to be
meeting quite a resistance even if you
get control of these peace centers the
resistance is going to be enormous
and i'm not so sure they have a strategy
to deal with that jeff semple global
news
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians have
fled and more are expected though
getting out is getting much harder the
u.n refugee agency estimates more than
874 000 ukrainians have now crossed into
neighboring countries since russia
attacked well over half of them are in
poland the polish government says a
further 50 000 ukrainians are arriving
every day
our mike armstrong is in poland about
100 kilometers from the ukrainian border
canada's foreign affairs minister is
there too along with other canadians who
feel compelled to try to help the flood
of people who have left everything
behind
it's a tiny one-bedroom apartment that's
not actually home to anyone living in it
but it's safe
there are four adults and five children
from ukraine who've escaped the war to
poland they're basically the guests of
the woman who rented the apartment heidi
bachmann a farmer from bentley alberta
she's canadian with ukrainian heritage
and says that pulled her here these are
my people
you know if if my family hadn't if my
family would have stayed put in odessa
you know 100 years ago
this would be me this this is this is me
these are my people
just days ago these children were hiding
in bunkers they're young but they still
understood the explosions around them
meant danger
flying she
covered your ears
and
shivers the news coming out of their
hometown isn't good the russian military
says it is now in control of the city of
harassan and the videos coming out of it
seem to back that up they're russian
soldiers on familiar streets
ukrainians in this apartment left behind
their parents brothers and sisters
almost everyone they knew this woman's
husband said goodbye at the border and
turned back to help others escape too
many people call
help to help he's giving a lot of calls
to please please help help
um but
sometimes he
cannot
okay
all done now bachmann met these families
almost by chance they were referred to
her by a stranger she financed the first
part of her trip by selling a load of
grain the rest is coming from friends
who heard about what she's doing
every time i look at my bank account it
has more money in it
coming here bachmann thought she'd be
helping orphans possibly move to canada
it turned out the kids came with parents
the goal now is to help until they can
go home with her son rubbing her back
this woman says she doesn't know when
that will be or if her loved ones will
still be alive
but
we have a truly cruel war she says
now also in this city on this day
canada's foreign affairs minister
melanie jalee met with staff from
canada's embassy in ukraine they should
be in keefe when safety became an issue
they were relocated to western ukraine
and then eventually moved outside the
country to here
the minister says the staff is working
to help about 1200 canadians still stuck
in ukraine
escape
providing
even in terms of travel itineraries
making sure that people understand
what's the best way to get to poland um
logistics
now as for that 1200 number the minister
says it's likely even higher not all
canadians register when they travel and
that makes helping them harder donna
mike armstrong in poland thank you the
chief prosecutor of the international
criminal court says he is immediately
proceeding with active investigations
into possible war crimes committed in
ukraine and says work on collecting
evidence has begun
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
said late today he spoke with prime
minister justin trudeau by phone
thanking him for imposing sanctions and
stressing the need to expand restrictive
measures
a kremlin spokesperson admitted today
the russian economy has suffered a
serious blow from economic sanctions
the moscow stock exchange stayed closed
for a third day today on the london
stock exchange russian companies have
lost 98 percent of their value in two
weeks wiping out 572
billion dollars in value russian energy
giants and big banks have been reduced
to penny stocks and the list of
companies that have stopped doing
business and selling products to russia
keeps growing today canada goose and
apparel manufacturer joined dozens of
global brands suspending sales to russia
netflix google apple boeing and
mercedes-benz are among the companies
which have cut ties video game maker
electronic arts says it is removing
russian teams from this year's nhl and
fifa games
one of russia's richest men and oligarch
who made his riches by seizing control
of the country's assets when the soviet
union collapsed has escaped sanctions
but roman abramovich now says he's
willing to sell the chelsea football
club in a statement the billionaire who
owns mansions yachts and jets says he
believes the sale is in the best
interest of the club abramovic says
he'll use all the net proceeds to
benefit victims of the war in ukraine
exactly howe isn't clear abramovic has
not explicitly condemned the invasion or
criticized putin he bought the premier
league club in 2003 pumping millions
into buying top players
anti-war protests continue in russia
this is in st petersburg people rallied
around this elderly woman as she as
russian police moved in to take her away
she was one of more than 200 people
reported to have been arrested during
this rally groups monitoring the
protests estimates some eight thousand
anti-war demonstrators have been
detained across russia since the
invasion began
the canadian government says 460
additional canadian troops are being
deployed to latvia but they haven't
arrived yet those who were already on
the ground are preparing for what might
come 540 soldiers are training to defend
against a possible attack should russia
extend its aggression beyond ukraine
mercedes stevenson reports from latvia
lieutenant colonel dan rochelle is the
nato battle group commander on the
ground in latvia it's his job to help
deter a russian invasion here and be
prepared if vladimir putin attacks our
mission here is focused on deterrence
and a defensive capability
um we do a lot of training in order to
be ready and this battle group already
has a very high state of readiness
to be able to go from a training posture
to an operational posture
very quickly a necessity given these
troops would be the first canadians to
fight we train primarily for a defensive
scenario
where
there could be an escalation of tension
where we may have to ramp up deterrence
activities all the way up to actually
defending the territorial integrity of
latvia there is a renewed meaning and
urgency to this exercise canadians are
practicing tactics aimed at a superpower
with superior firepower
one part of an institution-wide shift
after years of focusing on
counter-insurgency and roadside bombs
here the focus is on fighter jets
artillery tanks and missiles
a change in tactics to cyber defenses
and concealing equipment
smaller mobile headquarters just two
vehicles back together with a tarp
while training for the worst canada's
task force commander doesn't want to
exaggerate the threat i'm not worried
that we're going to have to deal with
invasion in the short term despite
russia's aggression in ukraine the
colonel says nato troops are effective
and so is deterrence vladimir putin
knows the consequences of attacking a
nato country i wouldn't say that that
trance is not working against russia you
know the the ukrainian crisis is one
thing
he has not attacked the nato country for
troops on the ground here they want
canadians to know one thing they're
ready and they're doing their best i
just want to reassure canadians that
their soldiers are always constantly
working hard
and we're vigilant and we're
doing our best to represent canada on
the world stage now it just becomes that
much more important that we we maintain
that focus and that we get ready for
whatever we might have to face mercedes
stevenson global news riga
the sanctions against russia keep piling
up coming up the new measures punishing
putin and the richest russians
[Music]
at the united nations general assembly
russia has been denounced by much of the
world the vast majority of member
countries voted to condemn russia today
and called for the immediate withdrawal
of its troops from ukraine canada says
more sanctions against russia are coming
in the days ahead jackson proskow on the
pressure the world is exerting
in a remarkable sign of unity
three-quarters of un members voted to
condemn russia's war with ukraine
even moscow's allies china and iran
chose to abstain rather than support
putin they have come to deprive ukraine
of the very right to exist it came after
an emotional plea from ukraine's
ambassador
and firm warnings from the u.s that
civilians could soon face exceptionally
lethal russian weapons now it appears
russia is preparing to increase the
brutality of its campaign against
ukraine russia dismissed it all as a
western pressure campaign one that is
squeezing moscow at every level
airplane makers boeing and airbus are
the latest western corporations to cut
off supplies to russian companies while
the u.s announced deeper sanctions
nothing is off the table the white house
has fully blocked russia's defense
sector and taken aim at putin's allies
in belarus
during his state of the union address
tuesday president biden announced plans
to target russia's elite oligarchs
directly we're joining with european
allies to find and seize their yachts
their luxury apartments their private
jets russia is now so deeply isolated
the u.s secretary of state assured
everyday russians that they are not the
target the economic costs that we've
been forced to impose on russia are not
aimed at you
they're aimed at compelling your
government to stop its actions to stop
its aggression so far none of it has
convinced putin to blink
yet nato allies remain steadfast that
there's only so far they're willing to
go the u.s insists it has no plans to
get directly involved in the conflict
and it's rejecting that repeated request
from ukraine to establish a no-fly zone
one that would stop russian airstrikes
jackson prosko global news washington
canada's interest rate rise ahead why
it's going up and what it means
[Music]
the bank of canada has raised its key
interest rate for the first time since
2018 and several banks quickly followed
suit this is also the first increase
since the start of the pandemic when the
key rate was cut dramatically it's
intended to help slow the surging cost
of living though the bank admits outside
factors including russia's invasion of
ukraine mean inflation will continue to
rise
and gaviola explains how all this could
impact you
with inflation raging at levels not seen
in three decades the bank has taken a
first step towards taming it though many
factors stoking inflation are beyond the
bank's control here's what a 25 basis
point hike means for a 700 000 home
that's the average home price in canada
with a typical five-year variable rate
mortgage that's an extra 73 dollars a
month nearly 900 a year
re max expects this hike and ones in the
near future to have a temporary calming
effect on the housing market it's going
to take some froth out of the market and
actually have a positive long-term
effect because
what we're seeing or what we have seen
over the last several months
is not sustainable but the modest rate
hike isn't the only thing affecting
household budgets
the unprovoked invasion of ukraine by
russia is a major new source of
uncertainty according to canada's
central bank already the conflict has
spiked prices at the pumps
right now metro vancouver has the
highest gas prices in north america and
there's more sticker shock in store at
pumps across the country if the conflict
continues beyond this month it could
take a bite out of growth just as the
economy returns to pre-pandemic levels
the question is how long will it last
when you look through many of you know
the last uh 30 40 years
you tend to get shorter durations which
would suggest it won't impede their rate
path however this is really a historic
moment and we you know can't predict the
duration in a recent survey more than
half of households were concerned about
the impact of rising rates on their
finances and 35 percent said any rate
hikes could push them towards bankruptcy
the stakes are high for the bank of
canada as it weighs the size and the
timing of the next rate hike which could
come as early as six weeks from now ann
gaviola global news toronto
westjet airlines says it is buying
sunwing airlines an effort to expand its
footprint in the holiday travel market
westjet ceo says the deal will
consolidate the airlines but sun wing
vacations and westjet vacations will
continue to operate as separate brands
financial terms of the agreement were
not disclosed the agreement is subject
to regulatory approval and that's
expected to close late this year
the united nations has approved a plan
to create the world's first global
plastic pollution treaty the resolution
lays out a framework to rein in soaring
plastic pollution the goal is to
establish rules and standards about the
production use and disposal of plastics
around the world nearly 200 countries
have agreed to it in principle it's
being hailed as the most significant
green deal since the 2015 paris climate
accord international negotiations will
now begin with a legally binding treaty
expected to be finalized by 2024
ukraine's hospitals strained by war next
the canadian efforts to help save lives
[Music]
one of the costs of war is the
staggering toll it takes on civilians
the crush of victims and the attacks on
medical infrastructure is fueling a
health crisis in ukraine critical care
has become difficult to provide experts
say the time to help is now as jamie
morocco reports canadians are answering
the call
and a warning some of the images are
disturbing
there's no time to stop no time to think
bombarded with casualties doctors and
nurses at this ukrainian hospital work
around the clock to save lives this is
beyond a scale i think that anyone has
seen this is more on the scale of what
you might see in the second world war
toronto-based plastic surgeon dr olie
antinocion has done countless medical
missions in ukraine reconstructing the
faces of injured during the crimean
crisis
there are hospitals he says are less
equipped and face challenges on a good
day he's assembling a canadian team to
go back without the urgent help
intention fears ukraine's health care
system will crumble they're under the
strain of constant bombing and not being
able to operate during hours and power
failures and cyber attacks and
everything else you can possibly imagine
makes it difficult to function
already patients and staff have been
displaced moved to makeshift maternity
wards and bomb shelters and pediatric
units in basements there's a shortage of
cancer medication insulin and oxygen and
it's unclear how the world health
organization will get aid into war zones
inside ukraine this family physician
received medical kits from a small
calgary-based organization but
dispensing them he says is proving
difficult some of the cities are
surrounded by russians and they don't
give us green corridors to to to give
the supplies to the cities
necessities the 32 year old worries will
be completely depleted in mere weeks
putting more lives at risk and
threatening the fundamental human right
to health care
jamie morocco global news toronto
it's been said that russia's war in
ukraine is a clash between the rule of
law and the rule of the gun between
democracies and autocracies we leave you
tonight with the words of a special
adviser to ukraine's president andre
yermack he says he is at the side of
president vladimir zelinsky in a bunker
in kiev
his appeal to the west was published in
a special editorial in the new york
times we will fight to the last breath
to protect our country he writes but
make no mistake other autocrats are
watching taking lessons
mr putin's forces will continue to
terrorize the country to induce
surrender if they don't succeed they
will burn it all down it's either bow or
vanish
no third option is allowed
we beseech our western allies and
partners to make the costs unbearable
for russia now
ukraine is not asking for its allies to
put boots on the ground
we need anti-tank and anti-aircraft
weapons and other ammunition delivered
to our brave soldiers right now
we are calling on the west to impose a
no-fly zone over ukraine
every day brings the possibility that
our words may be our final ones
so let them be a plea for support for a
free ukraine
[Music]
you